真的很討厭上了一種臉上的明顯的顆粒感很感
被個人感覺
我的妝感很重皮膚很差
所以雖然我是一個勇皮
普妝的細膩度
在我這裡的視
第一重要的
我喜歡那種那種皮膚太差
比較好那樣乾淨通透的一妝感
今天天真習是我從幾十塊分的一選傳
雖然有一些網絡
各種家裡都有妝感好看
用吃妝還不會蠻鬥的
我昨天是這個很長
其實我在二二年就做過對院測試
粉質非常非常吸引
其實特别薄
用手都很好的抹凌
很色滑有點像在圖欺騙
我自己平得感覺
上臉後就是給人一種
4月鏡頭
不論是偷老的貴婦積感
你看就是日子過得很濃郁的那種
雖然雖然雖然不是很高
但是舒適的效果很棒
也不暗沉帶妝的膩
在貴婦很妝裡面是很好的
那他就是我帶妝是十二個小時
下來他演出的
在我臉上出油
不會那種搬火
粉都會粉變成為鼓舞
按鈴按鈴是很完略的領裝
那時候的粉變為一樣
給你們按鈴塊
給你一場按鈴塊
他的這個款式
特别臭的仔細
上臉之後感覺是照顧
小薄的沙一樣
又不明的就種角
很自然的體量無色
但是又不會假面甲的
防禮是兩個上粉電視
頭突然味似綁善之間
跟他非常快速的出門
直雙力也是很暗
在線的好幾次
用他從去上不拉曲課
我留了一年的漢
但是裝飾一點都沒有獨
而且出油量三六月平時
很容易上了很多
而且這薄薄的一個
都算是放在那種小薄的
最薄裡面
也不佔定方
帶出的補裝很方便
像油皮下天出油多了
我們會練上有些損芳
在這裡跟你們分享
各種裝小品牙
就是先用他們家的那個西油
是把熱量上的油光給按壓掉
然後再反正分裂別的圖上去
他的用你的裝開上去
像是剛花的一樣
其實還是一個來
油脂分裂別的
雖然是補或加深重起來
真的很珍惜
跟我有過的規築
從什麼時候很屬於
至於很滋滑
我再練上一下子就可以
跟我的皮膚的彎質
而且很屬於
我之前失過
帶裝一整天
眼影都暈掉了
但是他還是狼狼的
巴特變質
不脫裝也不暗成
和油皮的失業都很港
就是他們家的這個色號
真的是很好的水
我只有用的CN0依裁
不覺得黑
但就是這個
他算是油皮分裂你的狼狼
主打的就是
食色是裝確實
我以後很屬於
裝而色是用越來越美麗的
質地是那種塑乾淨的
折甩力
比我之前很想過的狼狼
都讓起
剛上臉會有人擔憂
A、CN0依製化的裝
但屬於的比裝
一定失落了
很貴的那種乾淨
雖然有你的折甩力
但是不想念
出油之後會帶臉上
是一種
非常微妙的光澤
感悠心
整個裝甩
氣痛
而且用了他
不管是做運動
還是搭下貼的
去吃火鍋
它都不代表的
但就是這款
中藏要很爽
這個我只是做個特品的
它的優點
就是很氣和油動機
不管你是正在著動
還是很暗漲的
都可能用它
上臉是那種
微光澤的奶油機
就算你眼上有很多的
下臉的時候
但是你用了它
就會有沒有覺得
我的皮膚看起來很乾淨
我之前還拿
它和那個大臉定名的
你以前多的女革
我本來你一起做
作作要給你對結果
它就是
完全不舒適
長超越女環
概念到我臉上效果
最後是
習慣
前期間我買了好
我都好多
但是我發覺是
有時的肌臉是那種
它也上了
大部分的肌臉
都不吃妝
非常容易冷妝
這才是假的就是
有體肌臉
食妝的層層
粉質也很吸引
跟臉發得很忙
剛上臉
有種鮮魚水光河
霧面之間的一種
微光澤感
除了有之後
臉上就是那種水光雞
但你像鮮身好皮
而且它一天都不會暗沉
我出去一行
最愛帶的這個它
很方便